[Musique]
elle fait rêver toute l'équipe de france
250 mètres de long sur 8 mètres de large
et avec une pente plus importante
qu'ailleurs de 44 degrés la piste du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
permettra aux cyclistes de faire tomber
les records du monde et c'est aussi dans
sa composition même que ce bois venu
tout droit de sibérie délivre ses
secrets là la particularité d'être une
essence très dur de croître très
lentement et donc d'être très peu soumis
aux variations d'hydrométrie c'est un
des matériaux qui permet aussi d'avoir
le plus de rendement donc de restituer
l'énergie à des coureurs et ce qui est
très important pour pouvoir gagner de la
vitesse et des kilomètres dans la
configuration compétition près de 5000
spectateurs pourront garnir les gradins
et assister à d'autres événements
sportifs ou musicaux
cette structure unique abritera
également le nouveau siège de la
fédération française de cyclisme
depuis quelques semaines les deux rampes
de départ de l'arenh de bmx et le
traçage des bosses sont sortis de terre
les sportifs seront hébergés sur place
dans ce bâtiment juste en face de
l'entrée principale
tout cela pour un investissement total
de 68 millions d'euros
l'ouverture est prévue le 13 janvier
2014 avant une inauguration officielle
le 30 qui verra le remake de la finale
de vitesse par équipes des derniers jeux
olympiques entre la france et la grande
bretagne
[Musique]
médéric est un féru de jeux vidéo il
possède toutes les dernières consoles
raté la sortie de la nouvelle nintendo
était inimaginable il ya une bonne
qualité de jeu
c'est nouveau et
il s'assure aucune console à la veille
de la sortie de cette nouvelle machine
visiblement révolutionnaire il est venu
en famille réservé ce qui sera son
unique cadeaux pour noël aujourd'hui il
a demandé de l'argent à tous à toute la
famille
en fait pour pouvoir s'acheter sa vie et
s'il n'y a pas assez il remettra de son
argent de poche pour voilà chacun mais
quelque chose contribuer à son cadeau de
noël voilà c'est pour ça que c'est
essentielle cadeaux ils seraient
plusieurs centaines comme médéric avoir
réservé alors oui dans ce magasin un
succès qui s'explique en partie par le
système de jeu inédit proposé qui permet
aux joueurs d'être plongés au coeur de
l'action mais aussi par le
conditionnement marketing quant aux prix
bien que largement inférieur à celui des
principaux concurrents sony et microsoft
il me semble qu'un argument secondaire
c'est vrai que le prix est une question
vraiment la fin fois c'est une fois
qu'ils ont réservé il pose la question
du prix le public saint quentinois
séduit semble aussi beaucoup plus
féminin que par le passé comme
l'attestent sandrine venu officiellement
réservé pour son marais les autres
consoles de jeu on les a tout eu mais je
joue jamais j'aime pas ça du tout donc
là pourquoi pas c'est un peu pour vous
quand même un petit peu c'est un petit
peu pour faire plaisir aux maris on va
dire voilà vendredi jour du lancement
officiel de la wii la plupart des
magasins ouvriront leurs portes une
heure plus tôt afin d'accueillir les
plus impatients certains ont réservé
depuis le mois d'août
[Musique]